foreign
okay let the record reflect the council
and their clients are present in the
courtroom good morning my name is Robert
Sykes this is Lawrence Fielder he and I
are the co-lead council here we also
have uh Kristen Van Norman
and Peter Sorensen all together we are
honored to represent Terry Sanderson
here at the end thank you
and the defense
thank you my name is Steve Owens I'm
here in town a firm called well I should
say Salt Lake City at a firm called that
person and Owens uh this is James Egan
Peter Jensen and we're all here for Miss
Paltrow
thank you
Mr Bueller you may begin well we were
skiing down
the bend the down the run and then and
then I heard this this this BL this this
scream and then I looked over and then
about you know maybe one or two seconds
and then I hear the scream and then and
then and then I see this this this year
just slam into the back of Terry
when she just slammed him how
hard very hard I mean very hard and so
Terry she hits him right directly in the
bag and so then uh then his skis are
like that you can see in your skin like
this
skis his skis actually the tips go out
like this and he falls face down so he's
kind of he's kind of spreading you and
he goes face down and gwyneth's on the
top of him and they go down like this
and then Gwyneth hits him and then
bounces off and slides to the right
about five or ten feet